have you got half a million bucks to
spare for a painting to go over your
mantelpiece
well there are bargains galore to be had
out there this
recently discovered 16th century
portrait of the longest reigning ottoman
sultan suleiman the magnificent recently
sold for just under 500 grand
at sotheby's in london that guy
certainly knows
how to do noses or for half a mill you
could have picked up this
lorenzo de beachy painting 14th century
italian master of saint catherine of
alexandria with the six virtues and
christ the redeemer
above uh if your tastes incline
elsewhere
for 500 g's you could have got this daga
or this renoir or this picasso but
you're probably thinking look for
half a million greenbacks i don't want
some lousy picasso or some
post-impressionist gal with a
dress sliding off her bosom or some
downer old master dude hung up on saints
i'm looking for a real bang for my buck
ladies
and gentlemen for a mere 500
000 you can now buy a genuine
wait for it a genuine hunter biden
if you're wondering what that is it's
the surviving strip of hunter's tie-dye
shirt from his seventh birthday party in
1977
next to some valvoline 10 w30 he huffed
out of his rental car and blew through
his
art pipe yes usually you have to be dead
to fetch half a million but hunter's not
dead he's just sleeping it off he's only
been a professional painter since
oh let me see now uh around about
lunchtime on january the 20th
before then his art fetched a buck 79
from the last day grab bag table at the
ladies aid rummage sale
but since january 20th he's caught up
with picasso and dager and leonardo can
feel him nipping at his heels
the art critic martin galindo reacted to
this masterpiece
by saying oh my god that looks like
covid
he's not wrong here's the coronavirus
and here's hunter's version the
coronavirus stuck
on the end of his crack pipe but
hunter's covet painting is an art world
super spreader infecting
everyone in sight do you remember a
couple of years back when
impressionable kazakh oligarchs and
saudi princes
were mysteriously eager to pay the
clinton foundation
two million bucks for a speech by
chelsea on diarrhea in africa
well hunter's half million dollar corona
scape is the clinton foundation diarrhea
speech
of contemporary art do you have a
holbein rubens a gainsborough monet
sell them all matter of fact don't
bother selling them give them to your
undocumented nanny
she'll be able to get a couple of bucks
for the frame
the uh peerless art critic raymond
arroyo he doesn't know much about art
but he knows what he doesn't like
uh what do you what do you feel
about uh the the mysterious uh explosion
in hunter biden's art prices
mark you nailed it look the clinton
foundation they had their that was their
uh proxy
to get influence and and favors the
biden family has
hunter's art sale but the the
problematic thing is here you have the
white house
that has come out with its own ethical
protocol
they say look anybody buying hunter's
art
will be kept anonymous no one will know
so therefore that will
uh absolve us of any influence peddling
the truth here is you're relying on the
guy
at the gallery selling hunter's art
that's the ethical
benchmark that's the firewall i'm not
all that
confident that he won't tell hunter or
what's to stop mark
somebody sauntering up to joe or jill
biden or a member of the biden uh
administration and saying you know i
paid two million dollars for the
hunter's baby mama collection i expect a
little access this afternoon
i mean we know hunter and joe's
finances were connected we see that in
the laptop
so this is very worrisome or it should
be this sounds like the same
hunter biden grift without the frequent
flyer miles
it's actually a better racket than the
clinton foundation because
as you explain there's there's no need
for the uh relevant uh kazakh oligarch
who suddenly decides he's going to be an
art collector for his name ever to
emerge is there no no and i love
i love these art critics who are saying
well this is a little bit like
kurt cobain's sweater everyone will want
to own this because of its historic
value
wait a minute kurt cobain was a pop
culture icon
hunter biden god bless him his only
accomplishment is being joe biden's son
running up a tab at strip clubs and some
diamond status points at the rehab
clinics i mean
let's be honest and when you look at the
art as you showed earlier mark
this is not exactly george sarat i mean
let's let's be honest
this looks like rorschat splatter or as
you said
covet under the glass it's not edifying
now i think someone called it bad hotel
art
and i certainly am never going to check
in at any uh
any hotel that's hanging hunter biden in
the lobby
uh thank you for that raymond and we
will uh we will see you with
uh with with laura either tonight or as
the week
goes on thank you thank you very much
tomorrow
okay friday i've lost all track of time
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else